30 octobre 1979 le ministre du travail
robert boulin est retrouvé mort dans un
étang proche de rambouillet en région
parisienne commence alors l'une des plus
mystérieuse affaire de la cinquième
république à l'époque pour les
enquêteurs et les médecins légistes la
thèse du suicide ne faisait aucun doute
dans la voiture de monsieur moulin des
enquêteurs ont trouvé un tube noir vide
qui aurait pu contenir les barbituriques
sur le tableau de bord un bristol sur
lequel était écrit un court message
d'adieu adressé à sa famille quelques
mois avant sa mort robert boulin était
pressenti pour le poste de premier
ministre du président valéry giscard
d'estaing mais un scandale immobilier
impliquant le ministre vient
compromettre cette éventuelle promotion
la sphère l'aurait alors poussé au
suicide
une théorie que certains mettaient déjà
en doute une semaine après la tragédie à
l'assemblée le député ps laurent fabius
interpellé alors le gouvernement
l'opinion éprouve à propos du décès de
monsieur boulin en même temps que
l'émotion une très grande perplexité
les motifs des circonstances les
conditions exactes
tout cela n'apparaît pas clair réponse
immédiate du premier ministre de
l'époque raymond barre
je joue répond le gouvernement ne suis
pas dans un premier temps la famille de
robert boulin envisage aussi la thèse du
suicide mais les photos de la dépouille
du ministre obtenus par leurs avocats
révèle un visage tuméfié
en 1983 la femme et les enfants de
robert boulin réclame l'exhumation du
corps et porte plainte pour assassinat
pourquoi ne croyez vous pas au suicide
de votre main parce que mon mari était
blessé je cherche une vérité et la
vérité faut qu'elle sorte un an plus
tard en 1984 le nouveau rapport de topsy
tombe plusieurs fractures sont constatés
sur le visage du ministre
le crime d'état ne fait plus aucun doute
pour la famille boulin notre question
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir maintenant
qui a cogné qui a tué et pourquoi
malgré ces nouvelles preuves le juge
d'instruction prononce un non-lieu est
conclu au suicide
en 1980 la famille fait alors appel de
cette décision
nous avons droit de savoir la vérité et
aucune raison d'état privé entre
guillemets ne permettra de dire que
c'est un suicide
alors que nous avons la preuve que la
nasa cinar d'autres preuves et
témoignages continueront ensuite de
s'ajouter au dossier nourrissant un peu
plus la thèse de l'assassinât politique
en 2015 face à ces nouveaux éléments
l' enquête judiciaire est ouverte pour
assassinat une bonne nouvelle pour la
fille de robert boulin après plus de
trente ans de batailles judiciaires j'ai
bon espoir effectivement que ce dossier
qui fait un mètre de haut maintenant
qu'ils m'ont toutes les contradictions
les lacunes les mensonges de de
l'enquète de l'époque puissent être
mises à jour
quarante ans après les faits la mort de
robert boulin on n'a toujours pas été
officiellement élucidées
[Musique]
oh